prepare you for the day that approaches
is the day of the great revolution
what come on tell me this ain't good Oh
God
welcome back parking lot hatch up lots
to fill you in on pitch me the next 911
what about this guy Moses Shabazz
classic lone wolf there's four of them
actually Becca lone wolves at the heaven
the Almighty commands us to bring that
knowledge to the street may you live to
see the accidental dominance of the
white race overthrown could you walk him
across the line of course we give him a
fake bomb and the guy tries to use it we
had to next bin Laden my mission is that
changed a lot of support people without
the gun way
what's office of fun some automatic
weapons
perhaps your army needs weapons no we
don't believe in guns and if necessary
we'll call along the dinosaurs we
believe that at the sound of a trumpet
they will come to our aid I made a
mistake
I think he's delusional I smell doubt no
look I am just a guy standing here
talking to another guy trying to send a
third guy to J's here what did you know
if you can pay us $50,000 I can show you
a man trading ak-47 he did just report
us as the threat
this is his get out of jail card his get
out of jail card is going to jail
[Music]
it's just a horn they used to summon the
dinosaurs we know this inversion she is
groundless correct but the emergency
exists right and you can't take control
of something if it saying it doesn't
exist so just stop a nuclear emergency I
have to declare a nuclear emergency say
it slowly keeps the contradictory
elements apart then I guess we have a
nuclear emergency good play agent
[Music]
you